[Music]
[Applause]
chris carter hall of famer he is uh
starting a new podcast in association
with blue wire and win bet it's a wide
receiver one
wr1 launching this thursday and he talks
to wide receivers every week and uh not
just about football but also life and
everything in between
he's got julian edelman alan robinson
calvin johnson mike evans and jarvis
landry chris carter joining us how are
you chris
dan how you doing buddy i'm doing okay
what does what's the common trait
uh characteristic with all these
receivers what do you what do you have
to have
you have to be able to catch the
football
um
you have to have a desire to continue to
learning about the craft
and
you can't be contact adverse
like you you have to
enjoy the contact part of playing the
position okay how do you get
acclimated to getting hit that you
you kind of welcome the contact
well there's certain things in every
business that
you know they're not the glorified
aspects of the business and it's not
that you have to
like getting hit you have to understand
that if i understand the x's and o's it
can prevent a lot of collisions
but on occasions the quarterbacks gonna
throw me in there and the defense is
good too and you have to give them
credit so it's accepting
um some of the hazards that go along
with playing the position
what's the best piece of advice you
could give to a
rookie wide receiver like jamar chase
with the bengals who's having a case of
the drops what would you tell him
well all three of those catches were
were fairly difficult catches if you
look at the first one on third down um
the corner was off and in man
the ball was a little bit behind him on
his back hip a lot of times you're gonna
get that in those short yardage
situations so he drops that one not a
very difficult catch but i understand
the ball being behind
the next um play
the coverage they understood where he
was coming so he was kind of bracketed
so the corner kind of forced him inside
and the cornerback the quarter delivered
the quarterback delivered the ball but
the safety was breathing on him so he
had to make up his mind do i lunge for
this pass and get hit by the safety
and you know you could see the alligator
arms in that aspect and then the other
one he was running the smash route
against man to man that's the worst
coverage to have against that five yard
dig inside because you have nothing to
get the guy off of so it was going to be
a tough catch anyway so me that's that's
part of learning how to play in the nfl
trying to get more separation
and realizing sometimes on that catch
number two um it doesn't make sense to
reach for that ball and that safety hits
you and hit you in your face potentially
uh what do you think is going on in
larry fitzgerald's mind right now
he's probably counting his money
i don't think he's going to play for
free he's definitely not going to play
for the minimum
um
to me arizona they they have moved on
now they might have told him that maybe
late in the season but when you sign aj
green and you put him on a one year you
have deandre hopkins arguably the best
in the business um
you know and he's got a hefty price tag
and they got some good younger receivers
that they've drafted over the last
couple years so he's had a great career
the one thing that we all have in common
when we play is one day you got to go
some of us last longer than others
some are invited i mean tom brady was
not invited back to play in new england
that's why he went to tampa bay um and
that's why he went super bowl seven with
tampa bay wasn't because
you know new england was just oh they're
offering buckets of money no they didn't
offer him a contract and larry
fitzgerald i think is facing a similar
fate
but he's 150 catches away from jerry 115
away from jerry rice's number
um
if he wants to catch like 40 passes over
the next three years because uh you know
larry
you know he's not getting that much
separation
and ultimately
you come to the end of your career like
it's um he's taking the spot away from
another young player
that should be developing out there
playing that's the reality too
but but when do you know it's time like
you said you don't create separation i
don't know if larry has created
separation for quite some time now but
he was still a very valuable asset to
that offense but as a wide receiver
when do you know
well it's a combination of things you
know is someone going to allow you to
play that you can make a contribution to
the game
and that's what he's been able to do the
last several
years um there in arizona um when do you
know it's very very difficult because
he's not going to find a job that's like
playing in the nfl
so
you're you're like a boxer do i take
another fight and find out during the
fight that you know something i should
have retired on the last fight so it's a
tough tough situation um i believe you
should play as as long as a team is
going to pay you to play you should do
it because there is no coming back and
there is no job that would replace being
an nfl player
are gloves performance enhancing
um i just think that
you know given technology we have to
embrace technology so um
yeah the gloves they do help the wide
receivers and
defensive backs linebackers running
backs tight ends
they all benefit from it
so
you know it's not it's not just the wide
receiver's advantage it's the technology
the cleats are better the helmets are
better the shoulder pads are better the
material the jerseys are are made in is
better uh the gradient rate is a little
bit better so it's all better
i mean
what are we talking about
um you didn't wear them as a rookie
yeah because we didn't wear gloves at
ohio state unless it was a certain
temperature
so you just when you got into the league
you you weren't wearing them because you
didn't wear them at ohio state
i mean i just started off not i didn't
think i i needed them and then when the
season is extended in college you play
in you know big blue
in late november nfl man you got you got
five or six more games potentially and
it's cold on the east coast and that win
and
guys delivering the ball in the nfl
throw the ball harder the nfl ball has a
larger circumference and when it gets
cold the point of it gets it's a little
bit harder
so it's harder to catch than any
football out there so
gloves become necessary um with playing
in the nfl especially with the extended
season and if you're on the east coast
what do you think we're going to look at
with wide receiving numbers as we move
on with this chris when we're looking at
the hall of fame that it used to be if
you got to a thousand catches like
you're a hall of famer now we're looking
at a thousand catches and going i don't
know
like this this past happy league now
even even the quarterbacking numbers
here like what's that going to do and
what's it going to do to running back
numbers can we say if you get to 10 000
yards
as it used to be that you're a hall of
famer i'm just curious about these
numbers with the way the nfl is going
well i think you have to adjust the
numbers and um it is only one game so if
you look at a guy who plays larry
fitzgerald if he was to start his career
today and he was a place 17 seasons
i played 16 seasons so it really just
gives him
you know 17 more games than me over a
career which is really not that much you
know if you're out there playing so the
numbers have to be adjusted just like
any other sport
you know i think that you know to me
we've always looked at you know 11 50
1200 yards as far as the receiver um
now you know i believe it's probably
going to be around 1300 yards um you
should be expecting the top receivers
and i think that though the top guys
will catch between 145 and and 160 um as
far as you know
because they're targeted so much so i
think 145 maybe a little on the 160 that
that that would be the number when
someone's having a record-breaking year
who was the defensive back that
just figured you out
or frustrated you the most
well i don't um
i don't think you get to the hall of
fame with someone figuring you out
um so
you know to me
i was in an era where there were some
great great
you know
defensive backs it was at the end of the
era
where were michael haynes and you know
arguably he's one of the people that
invented the the bump and run
so then you get into the ronnie lot
you get into the rod woodson dion
sanders daryl green
aeneas williams like all these guys i
played against multiple times
so
what i've all the best way to try to
describe it is
when you're playing as a player like
that you're trying to have a stalemate
you're like you're trying to draw even
in that match up to give your team um
still an advantage because he's not
dominant like he is in the other games
like you can't go into these matchups
thinking i'm getting ready to dominate
aeneas i'm getting ready to dominate
daryl green no you want to have a
stalemate with them but if they slip up
you're going to be able to make some
plays against them and that's what's
happened they've made some plays against
me i've made some plays against them but
i think that grouping of people
if there was a skill set um that i would
take of any of the db's that i faced i
would say dion
because he's a lot taller than people
think
he's a technician more than people think
his arms are longer than people think
and bunker bump and run is the toughest
coverage and he has that ketchup speed
daryl green has it but daryl doesn't
have to have the size of dia and daryl
is more apt to let you off the line of
scrimmage compared to dion he's going to
fight you at the line and not give you
an easy release so
the skill set the body type um the
sizzle i got to go with dm
did you ever talk trash while the ball
is in the air
no
no that's that's a that's impossible to
do
like the game is very very hard
the motor and skills to be able to catch
a football and try to keep defenders and
everything off of you
no that's one of the few times
i know you might be a little surprised
yes
sometimes did you have your mouth yes
like even a person like you if you were
a wide receiver you wouldn't be able to
talk and run routes and everything
i would try though
i would i would
you know on that that slant route that
i'm famous for i would i i would do that
no the ball's up in the air and you're
going deep and you're like oh you're
going to get burnt like i would i come
on
i think that
it's just too it's too difficult to
track a ball too many things can go
wrong
um and you've got your full focus on on
that football when it's in the air
do you have a motion
do you have a play that still bothers
you
at night
no
you don't think oh god i dropped that
ball
no i think the you know the atlanta game
of the 98 team i'd like like to be able
to make another play in the game to give
us an advantage and give us a chance to
go to the super bowl but
no
no if there was something that's going
to get me to the super bowl i would be
like yeah that you know tom brady went
ten i would like one one trip
would you rather catch a ball from
rogers mahomes are brady
rogers my homes are great
um
i'm probably gonna say patrick mahomes
because i'm about velocity the more
velocity you have on the ball the more
rpms the less reaction time the defense
has and the more
the more aggressive you can be on the
defense so
it's not because i think he's better
um aaron throws a a very good ball too
it's between those two and just because
they just have more rpms than than tom
brady if you you said one pass yeah now
if you're gonna play a game you're gonna
play a season you're gonna play anything
else tom brady's gonna win out on that
because
he's proved it i mean there's only been
55 super bowl he's been in town
like
yeah uh
i remember jerry rice said steve young
as a left-hander like he you know he
threw it it's a different ball coming
from a left-hander
do you do you buy into that
no it is the spin rotation yeah it's no
different than a pitcher
i'm gonna i was talking to dan marino
and i'm gonna go down and talk to the
dolphins uh probably before their first
regular season game
and that will be one of the things
that i will talk to them about
because
probably 70
or more of society is right hand
so most coaches even think right hand
most coaches are right hand most
coordinators are right hand most
quarterbacks are right-handed
so when you watch football
it's very very hard
to see
them operate on the left side of the
field people say well man with all the
schematics and analytics and everything
but you can't overcome who you are and
almost everyone is right-handed and the
right-handed quarterback when that when
they throw the football
the ball comes off going from right to
left because it comes off their hand
this way a left-hander when they throw
it it comes off this way so it's
spinning the opposite way
so for instance if i have a left-hand
quarterback in tua and i'm on the right
side and i'm a receiver and i'm running
anything that's breaking to the sideline
i have to be careful on my break because
the ball will tail back into the field
of play
all right if i'm running a deep route a
deep post and i stick the post he throws
it to me it's coming from a lefty it's
gonna spin away from me so i'm gonna
have to maybe hit another gear compared
to if i'm the receiver on the left and
he throws it to him the ball's probably
gonna come back over my head more up the
field
so those are the little things that then
we chart
and we make mental notes so that they
know that oh okay if i'm running out
breaking route on the left side he's a
lefty the ball is going to break away
from
it's
you can't overcome
the spin
and how the ball is going to be arriving
so the more information it's like new
england
the more information that they can give
to the player it allows the player to be
able to adjust and be successful and
those are some of the things i've been
teaching receivers for years talking to
chris carter he's got a new podcast in
association with blue wire and win bet
and uh it launches uh thursday wide
receiver one and uh
he talks to mike evans calvin johnson
julian edelman among the uh luminaries
there
maybe have lebron on and talk about him
when he was in high school as a wide
receiver
well the contact got it i think you know
the the the hi the people
um surrounding lebron he made all-state
his sophomore year but he broke his
wrist
and that kind of ended his his
football aspirations but as you have
seen through the years especially when
he was with the cavs oh he's a big
buckeye fan he shows up at the horseshoe
he has amazing gifts that he sends the
team
you know with his gear and everything
throughout the the last several years so
um we're glad to have him aboard could
he have been
moss could he have been t.o could he
have been calvin johnson
i think what he's done in the nba i
you know i don't
lebron's a tough guy in the nba i don't
know if he's a tough guy in the nfl
you know
it's like
if it was that easy usain bolt would be
playing somewhere
[Laughter]
but all of a sudden dan you know guys
come up out the surface and they hit you
and they say things to you
and
most track athletes they they don't have
that type of temperament
um
i would say nba toughness is a different
type of toughness in grit than what you
need to play in the in in the nfl now i
am going to tell you this
guys have been successful the last 25
years they're the basketball rejects
they're the guys that are small forwards
and they average about 10 12 15 points
you know in college and they're not good
enough to play in the nba antonio gates
gonzalez
these dudes jimmy graham
i call them basketball rejects because
nba didn't want them and they come into
the league and they dominate
because it becomes basketball on turf
so that is great to see that how the
scouting department is finding these
guys that um you know do have some
basketball backgrounds
it's great to catch up with you chris
and and chris had a great basketball
background as well probably could have
played basketball at ohio state couldn't
you
i could have definitely played
basketball ohio state yeah yeah
yeah but you know my football career was
already launched i had to i i when i
signed with ohio state i was supposed to
play both but then i got mvp in the rose
bowl and i got a little banged up and
then i really wanted to concentrate on
my academics and um the weight coach he
challenged me to be the first
all-american wide receiver in
110 year history i think it was at the
time
and he was like you need to be with me
at 6 00 a.m
twice during winter quarter and you'll
be the first all-american you'll get
that buckeye tree and i made a
commitment to him and we got it done how
would you have done one-on-one with moss
and basketball
i think moss is a little bit better than
me
he's a little longer than me
he's a little more athletic than me
[Music]
i think that him and i could play on the
same team because i could play the point
i'm not like you i don't have to play
the shooting guard i can and then i can
play some hell of a defense i think we'd
be a hell of a backcourt combination and
we have taken down many fools on the
basketball court on the same squad
straight cash homie yes he always picks
me
great to talk to you chris good luck
with the podcast and uh thanks for
joining us all right thank you dan
that's chris carter we'll take a break
last call for phone calls after this